Hey, everyone,
we are in chapter seven.
We're going to be looking at some work problems here.
And again, these are aligned to our ...
learning objectives, and they are designed to give ...
you a little bit of flavor for what you can expect to see ...
on quizzes and things like that.
So let's go ahead and take a look at our first question.
Refer to the table on the right.
What is the marginal product of the fifth worker,
and what does it show?
Now, remember,
the marginal product of labor is just the change in total ...
output as we move forward from one unit of labor to the ...
next unit of labor.
So we're looking at the fifth unit of labor here.
So from going from 4 to 5, our total output goes from ...
360 to 390, which means our marginal ...
product of labor is 30.
Now before that, from 3 to 4 units of labor,
we go from 300 to 360.
And so our marginal product of labor was 60.
In this case, what we see is that we have 30 units.
So a or B could possibly be answers.
But because our marginal product of labor is going from ...
60 to 30, what we see is diminishing ...
marginal returns.
So B is our answer.
That is, as we add more and more ...
labor, we get less and less in terms ...
of our marginal product from those each additional unit of ...
labor that we add.
All right, let's move to our next question.
A supplier's marginal cost rises steeply beyond 5,000 units.
What should a buyer consider when negotiating a ...
large purchase?
Now, what this looks like,
let's just draw this in right here.
We're going to have our marginal cost,
our output, we have something like 5,000 right here.
And it said our marginal cost rise steeply as we approach 5,000 units.
So that means the supplier's marginal cost curve and ...
where it steepens, why they want to consider ...
that is that if you're the buyer here and you're approaching ...
5,000 units, and you know that the ...
marginal cost of obtaining more than 5,000 units is ...
going to dramatically increase,
then you know you're going to end up paying a lot more ...
per unit than you would if you just stopped at 5,000 units.
So in this case, the buyer may want to know ...
this kind of information, so that way they can ...
negotiate better deals.
So that's why we should consider such a marginal ...
cost whenever we get to 5,000 units.
What the marginal cost curve does our next question refer ...
to? The table on the right.
At what output level does constant returns to scale set in?
Now, constant return is a scale.
Let's just draw it out here.
Remember, our economies of scale is ...
decreasing long run average cost.
Our constant returns of scale are basically flat long run ...
average total costs and our diseconomies of scale are ...
increasing long run average costs.
Let's put quantity there.
We'll put average cost here.
This is our long run average cost curve.
So what we're looking for is the section of the average ...
cost curve, the long run average cost ...
curve. That's flat.
So let's go in here and let's do some calculations lack.
So 1000 divided by 100 is going to give me 10.
1500.  Excuse me.
Nope, Tim was right.
And now 1500 divided by 200 gives me 7.5.
2250 divided by 300 gives me also 7.5.
4000 divided by 400 gives me 10.
And then 6000 divided by 500 gives me 12.
So in reality it could be B or, or C as the answer.
What we have here, output 200,
output 300 and what I should have done instead of doing ...
100, 200,
300, 400 is done.
It is done. Something like this.
100 to 200, 200 to 300 and 300 to 400 as ...
potential answer choices.
Because both B and C reflect constant returns to scale.
Because our long run average cost flattens out right ...
there, it decreases up to 200 and ...
then it increases after 300.
All right, let's move on to our next question.
As a firm increases output from 1,000 to 2,000 units,
its average cost per unit rises from $10 to $13.
What is this most likely an example of?
So our average cost is increasing from 10 to $13 as ...
our output is increasing.
So that means constant returns of scale in economies ...
of scale will not work in this case because that is when ...
we have either flat average cost or we have decreasing average costs.
Increasing returns of scale is typically related or actually is ...
related to marginal productivity of labor and ...
relates to the fact that we have increasing marginal ...
productivity of labor, which means typically we ...
have decreasing average cost.
So that means dis economies of scale is going to be our answer.
And that makes sense because remember,
diseconomies of scale is the portion of the long run ...
average cost curve that happens whenever average costs rise.
Let's put cost here and quantity here is the portion of ...
the long run average cost curve where our average cost ...
are rising as our output is increasing.
So D definitely makes sense as our answer.
Let's move on to our next question.
Why should firms consider learning curves when ...
introducing a new product?
Now, learning curves are those ...
things that allow us to see what happens whenever we ...
have cumulative production and how costs fall?
I guess I'm kind of actually giving away what the answer is here.
And that answer is going to be D.
So let me explain why this is important.
As firms begin to produce more cumulative output,
they learn from the previous process.
So as I go from one unit to two units,
two units to four units, so on and so forth,
the workers in the organization,
the firm itself, they learn from the ...
production process, which means that they can ...
reduce the cost in that cumulative output.
So this increases the efficiency of the firm.
It means they need less time, they need less cost to go into ...
actually making products.
That increases production efficiency helps with their ...
pricing and competitive strategy as well.
So this is why firms want to consider learning curves ...
whenever introducing new product.
Because over time, as cumulative output grows,
their costs are going to fall and they're going to become ...
more efficient in the process.
So that is why D is our answer.
Let's move on to our next question.
A company's labor hours to produce the first unit of a new ...
product is 100 hours.
When cumulative production doubles to two units,
the labor required to produce, labor required per unit drops to 75 hours.
What is the learning rate?
So the learning rate is going to be what we call what it costs us now.
Now, in this case,
we didn't use average costs, like what we have been using ...
in the tax and the PowerPoints and all that other stuff.
Instead, we're just using labor hours.
That's an approximate measure of our cost.
So our new labor hours at the two units,
the cumulative two units over what it used to take us,
multiply that by 100%, and this gives us 75%
as our learning rate.
So D is going to be our answer.
Now, why,
again, this matters,
why this learning rate matters is because it basically tells us ...
that at a 75% learning rate,
we have effectively dropped our production cost,
our per unit production cost. Let's write that in.
Per unit production cost.
Almost got it in there.
Per unit production costs have dropped by 25%
simply because the production process,
the workers involved, have learned how to produce ...
this more efficiently.
And so that's actually good for the firm in this case.
So that 75% learning rate translates into a ...
25% reduction in our per unit ...
production cost.
All right, let's move on to our very last question here.
And this is an economies of scope question.
Let's look at what it says.
If product A cost $60,000 to produce,
product B cost 50,000 to produce,
but producing them together cost 95,000.
What is the economies of scope savings?
So the cost of A is going to be 60,000.
The cost of B is going to be 50,000.
And the cost of A plus the cost of B together is going to be 110,000.
But if we jointly produce them together,
we figure out a way to jointly produce them together.
So the cost of A and B together is only 95,000.
So the economies of scope savings is basically going to ...
be CA plus CB over minus CAB,
and that's going to give us what?
$15,000.
So the economies of scope savings is $15,000.
Now, we can take it a step further,
plug it into our equation.
That is the CA plus CB minus the cab over the cab.
There we go. And this is going to give us ...
15,000 over 95,000.
I think that's something like 16 or so percent.
Now, what does this mean?
What does that 16% degree of economies of scope mean?
It means that if I produce good A and good B together,
it cost my firm 16% less to do so than producing ...
them separately.
So here we could start to get some type of competitive ...
advantage simply because we can get a 16%
cost reduction by producing these two goods together.
And that is how we look at our degree of economies of ...
scope. And that is it.
I hope you have enjoyed it.